keruson la forte tête est arrivée Éric
Cantona l'autre forte- tête annonce son
départ on ne le verrait plus si l'on en
croit ses propos sur un terrain de
football désormais il a pris tout le
monde à contrepied comme d'habitude les
réactions à cette annonce surprise du
côté de Manchester où l'on retrouve
Étienne
Lenart les journaux anglais ce matin du
côté de Manchester ont la gueule de bois
qu'antona a tiré sa révérence en douce
mais il le lui pardonne depuis hier en
fin d'après-midi les supp son cl de
Manchester viennent tour à tour échanger
des impressions dire leur tristesse et
leur admiration pour un joueur hors
norme qui a préféré partir en pleine
gloire longue vie au King au revoir er
et merci pour tout vous pouvez pas dire
Manchester sans
direon je préfère qu'il prenne retraite
plutôt que de le voir dans un autre
club nous achèter ces tableaux nous
achèterons s livres et s'il fait du
cinéma on IR le
voir sur le plan martingaffaire n'est
pas bne les figurines les tasses à café
les cassettes et les t-shirts à
l'effigie du roi se trouvent encore ce
matin dans les rayons mais elles vont
disparaître restera le souvenir de tant
de buts tant d'émotion et tant de
victoires
partagé c'est un jour triste il aura été
un joueur fantastique et il nous a fait
gagner six fois le
championnat bien sûr les supportes se
souviendront aussi des gestes interdits
des frasques des coups en douce parfois
inexcusables d'un football spectaculaire
et de phrases
sibiline quand les mouettes suivent un
bateau de pêche un chalutier c'est parce
que elle pense que des sardines seront
jetées à la mer merci le culte pour ces
dieux du stade ici à Old trford à
Manchester est on le sait bien éphémère
et éc Cantona ne fera sans doute pas
exception à la règle déjà dans les
coulisses les rumeurs vont bon train sur
le nom de celui qui pourrait lui
succéder dans les mois qui viennent dans
le cœur des supportes anglais